in FIFA 16 we have used the latest
cutting-edge technology to
motion-capture Lionel Messi's movement
and bring his unique abilities to the
game he demonstrated to us how dribbling
is about more than what you do with the
ball
sometimes the best touch can be the one
you don't a general appeal men
chec sewer juan de la posición quito
para intentar de entender symbol or
icons appear by Gemma oppositional under
a new no touch dribbling system allows
you to emulate Messi's ability to feint
and change direction while dribbling
without touching the ball then once
you've created the space to maneuver you
can exit using a new range of touches as
players react to defenders challenges
completely transforming 1v1 situations
when the Dutchman Romano's
can play my fuzzy Aumont almighty's is
better but only fence or Bernardino mass
myself pleasure engine and daring
moccasin yes and Isabella won't get love
no touch dribbling is a tool that all
footballers can use and just like in
real life better skill players will be
more effective at using it as well as
being a valuable new way to beat
defenders it allows you to let the ball
roll buying you the time to get your
shot away or pick the killer pass you'll
be able to use it alongside a whole host
of new features that create a more
balanced and exciting game
subscribe for future dev Diaries and
find out more about how we're innovating
all over the pitch